The following is a production of Frank Defratus and the Internet Museum of Holography.
Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratus, and welcome to HoloTalk for the week of November 23rd.
And happy Thanksgiving this week in case you happen to celebrate this holiday.
If you're a student or educator or someone who has an interest in making holograms as a hobby in your own home, studio or lab, I have got the most incredible news for you on the show tonight.
If this news doesn't rock the holography world, then nothing will.
Laser pointer.
I'll repeat that.
This hologram was made using a standard off-the-shelf and out-of-the-box $49 laser pointer.
The person who achieved this is Steve Michael, who is my guest tonight on HoloTalk.
Steve is going to tell us all the details of using a laser pointer to make holograms so that you too can now get involved with holography at a fraction of the cost of what is the most expensive part of any holographic setup, the laser.
Now before we begin the interview, let me give you some specific information on this laser pointer that Steve is going to tell us about during the interview.
It is called the Rocket Laser Pointer, Rocket ROCKET, and can be found in the Edmund Scientific Catalog.
Edmund Scientific is located in Barrington, New Jersey, and they can be reached at the following telephone number.
Area code 609-573-6250.
They will send you a catalog if you call and ask for one.
Ask for their latest optics catalog.
That's the one that I have that Its ordering number is D54,000 006.
That's D as in Dog 54,000 006.
And here are the specs.
It is a class 3A laser pointer.
Power output is 3 to 5 milliatts at 635 nanometers, which is very close to the HENE at 633 nanometers.
And it's also very close to the power of many of the lasers that you find in the classroom.
It runs on two LR 44 alkaline batteries and gets two and a half hours of continuous operation from these batteries.
Now as many of many of you may remember, last year I ran a series of webcam nights, which I which you could log on to the site and see a presentation in the studio.
I had a similar laser diode that I demonstrated, which was battery operated, that I had taken the diode out of the housing and hooked it up to a Radio Shack power supply to run the diode off of standard household current.
Saving you the money of having to replace batteries all the time by just plugging it into the wall.
So why is this such a big deal?
Well, it's certainly not a big deal if you're working with a 20 watt argon laser system, but for kids with school projects, teachers in the classroom, and many hobbyists and amateurs on tight budgets that really want to get involved with holography but could not do so.
This is going to revolutionize this type of holography.
Can I make a hologram using a laser pointer?
In the past I've had to write back saying that you can view a laser hologram with the laser pointer, but because of the short coherence length of laser diodes, you could not make a hologram until now.
So let's move on to the interview with Steve Michael and get the details.
He's also going to have information up at his site on laser pointer holography, and you can find a link to his site right on the HoloTalk page.
Now I won't be coming back on after the interview, so I will thank you now for tuning in to HoloTalk and hope that you continue to come back each week for new and exciting shows just like this one.
Here's the interview with Steve.
This is Frankie Freitas for Holotalk.
Let's get rolling and we'll start off with uh your website, which is an incredibly well done site for amateur and hobbyist holography, especially with the guide and everything that you have on there.
How did you get started with the website?
Uh, how long has it been up?
How much work did you put into it?
Could you let listeners know a little bit about that?
Yeah.
I um I wrote a couple papers in 1990 and 91 in the Journal of Biological Photography, and I wrote these papers so that uh beginners in the field of biological sciences might want to use uh holography for their uh recording medium.
And both one paper was called How to Build a Holography System.
And the other one was Producing Transmission and Reflection Holograms.
So I decided right now I'm working um on an internet team on a graphic arts team and I decided I'd it would be a good chance for me to set up a website and transfer that information so the rest of the world could see it.
And I did that in all I finished it in August of ninety six.
So it's been up for a little over two years.
And it took me about six hundred hours to produce all the graphics 'cause I had to do those from scratches, you know.
The background graphic that you have on there the laser pattern, did you do that?
Yes.
Is that the laser being sent through like a piece of plexiglass or something?
You've got it.
That's exactly right.
That's a great shot.
Technically it's a great photograph.
Oh thank you.
Yes.
Uh I projected it onto just a piece of white cardboard.
Uh set my camera up so that it was um in line with the direction that the pattern was being projected to the screen.
And just by I have a linear translation stage the sitting on and just by slightly moving the plastic I could change the pattern if you will.
And y and I had like thirty six or forty different patterns that I photographed and then um you know I did a Photoshop set it up for digital use.
Yeah, usually that saturates the film those types of shots, but that that's just like right on the money.
You have hologram Mart where you sell some of your own editions too, right?
Yeah.
What pieces do you have on there right now?
My original work um was in the biological sciences.
So I have a human skull and a sagittal section of a human brain.
And these were actual uh real specimens.
And then I did one of a lunar lander on the moon.
Which was a positive model in the landscape I created using uh clay.
The uh guide itself, is that something that you wrote as the site progressed or did you already have that written and you just put it up?
That's almost like a holography manual.
Yes, I wrote that that was the material I wrote in nineteen ninety and ninety one.
Mm-hmm.
And I just uh transcribed it over to HTML.
Uh w where do you have your lab?
Is it in your home?
Yes, it's in my basement.
Um what type of a table are you working on?
Well it's really interesting I have a glass table.
Oh really?
Yes.
Um I progressed from uh wooden table to sandbox to marble and now I have a five by eight foot three quarter inch thick glass table.
That's very interesting.
And it's all um gravity mounted.
The holograms that you sent me were produced on that table, right?
Yes, they were it's very uh stable, very rigid.
Now here's what everyone's waiting to hear.
I received as I said at the beginning of the show, two holograms from Steve.
A single beam reflection hologram and a single beam laser transmission hologram.
And these were really nice holograms.
And Steve you did them with a laser pointer.
That's correct.
Now my first question is is this just off the shelf or did you do something to the laser pointer?
No, this is one just off the shelf.
With um with batteries.
With batteries, three of 'em.
No kidding.
Yes.
And I bought the batteries you could buy a radio shack.
Yeah.
So it wasn't like a laser that you took the diode out of the pointer and hooked the diode up to a power supply or anything like that.
That's correct.
Just out of the box.
Right.
And you probably put tape or something and make it uh stay on, or did you have a switch or something?
Yeah, it's one of those uh momentary on switches.
And what I did was it was clamped in one of these vice clamps, the the actual laser was and I had the button turned in such a way that I could put a pencil in another clamp and push the pencil against that button and hold it in place.
Yeah.
So you uh you kinda have to work fast and your setup and then you turn your laser off and let it rest and I generally have several extra batteries ready to go because when I actually make my exposure I want fresh batteries in there because it'll give me the power I needed.
And how long do you leave that laser on for?
I mean most of the uh gas lasers like the helium and neon, they really say how important it is to allow that laser to reach thermal stability.
How long would you say the laser pen was on for before you would do your first exposure?
Approximately five minutes.
No kidding.
And what what power laser?
This is a uh three to five milliwatt.
Operating at do you know the wavelength?
Yes, uh it's at six four zero um zero nanometers.
Six four zero nanometers.
These holograms display an incredible amount of depth.
Yes, I was very interested in finding out uh what the actual coherent length of these were.
Um I had done some research and got some specs from companies on the more powerful dial laser lasers like the one, two and five watt lasers.
All of their specifications say that that the coherent length of these things were around three to four millimeters.
Mm-hmm.
And plus the fact that they're randomly polarized.
And I was concerned about that and being able to make a hologram.
So I was a little discouraged um that dials lasers would even work.
Exactly.
I mean the emails that I get always getting emails, you probably get them too.
Yeah.
Can I do a hologram with a laser pen?
And it's always been well you may be able to do something like a postage stamp or something like that, but you would never get any depth.
Mm-hmm.
Well I decided to not believe what I read and I went what I did was I went to Edmund Scientific dunk their uh rocket laser pointer.
Okay, the rocket laser pointer right out of the catalog.
Right out of the catalog.
They have numerous other ones and the wavelengths vary depending on which one you get.
Some of them are six hundred and seventy nanometers.
Six are s some are six fifty, six seventy five with the with the same model or with okay different yes, okay.
Right.
And so I got the one that was closest to six three two eight for the um the film I was using.
Because I was using eighty seventy five.
Oh okay.
And so now this laser by the way cost forty five dollars.
So right there we've brought the cost down from like, you know, a five milliwatt human neon from eight hundred dollars down to like forty five.
But um when I got it here in my lap, first thing I checked was to see if it was polarized.
And sure enough it was.
No kidding.
I I it it just blew me away.
I didn't think that was true.
Well, the next day I went to Radio Shack and and checked two of their other models that they were two models that they have there, and they were both polarized.
So I'm thinking I don't know whether all laser pointers are now, but at least three models are.
Yeah.
And then the next thing was I set up a microsen well I set up a Michelson interferometer to see if I could get fringe patterns.
And I was amazed right off the bat.
With the path lengths being zero, I got some really nice high contrast fringes.
I bet you thought you were really off and running then.
Yeah.
Um and then I decided I wanted to find out what the clearance length link was.
So I started to move one of the mirrors and I got it all the way out to ten inches.
Oh my goodness.
And I was still getting fringe patterns, very sharp.
Mm-hmm.
As you can see, that hologram I sent you is probably three centimeters deep.
Oh yeah, of of the horse, yeah.
Of the uh unicorn.
Yeah, easy.
Mm-hmm.
Easy.
It looks just like you shot it with a helium neon laser.
In fact I would go out on the limb and say it's better than a lot of the classroom laser uh holograms that I've seen as far as brightness and uh depth.
Well, I put the object as close as I could to the film so the path differences were minimal.
Yeah.
Um the other problem though with the diode laser is that it doesn't have a circular beam profile.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
It's rectangular.
Mm, or at least the one I have.
And I found that uh by the way, this particular diode laser pointer has a lens in front of the diode so you can focus it to a sharp point.
Oh you know, out to uh a hundred feet.
Mhm.
And if you actually do focus that to infinity it's a sharp point from the laser pointer all the way out to that distance.
But what I had to do was I had to adjust that lens such a way behind my microscope objective which was gonna diverge the beams cover the whole four by five plate in such a way that I got it uniformity across the plate.
And that was a little difficult.
I mean I I even used the pinhole to try to clean it up some.
Yeah.
But trying to put uh you know, it was trying it was like trying to put a rectangle through a a circle.
And I was getting diffraction effects.
Yeah.
What did your exposure time run on these shots?
It was one minute for the transmission and two minutes for the reflection.
Mm-hmm.
Hm.
So that that's pretty short.
Yeah.
I'm trying to think it's been a while since I've had a f a three or five milliwatt he but I'm trying to think of what the single beam exposure times would be on the eighty seventy five H D with the Heane.
Well, um I went and set up my five milliwatt unity in the on, which my power meter was saying was operated at about six point two milliwatts.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, my social time is about two seconds.
With a single beam.
That's interesting.
Why do you think the difference there it's not that much difference in the power?
Well I it could be the beam profile being spread out further that way.
I see.
It certainly didn't look as bright because I did take a power meter reading on the diodes laser when I had new batteries and I was getting three point three.
Mm-hmm.
There's about a three milliwatt difference.
Yeah.
Um which is half of what you were seeing with the Heaney, but yet more than twice the time on the exposure.
Right.
Um in any case, it's a wonderful job.
Oh thank you.
Beautiful hologram.
I mean that laser transmission hologram is is gorgeous.
And the reflection hologram as soon as the box was handed to me I opened the box up and uh with a lamp that I have on my desk I saw the image right away.
I did try a tubing setup.
And that was very difficult.
As a matter of fact I wasn't successful in getting the the plate covered uniformly and also being able to uniformly cover the object.
It's again a function of that lens in front of the diode, plus having to split the beam cut your power in half in each of them.
And so that's that's a bit difficult.
But for the student that wants to do a single beam for a science project it works great.
Well Steve I'm going to go out on a limb and I'm gonna say that probably what you've just done could very well revolutionize holography not only in this country but around the world.
That that's interesting you mean in terms of uh in terms of making it available to more people who will uh get involved with it and continue to grow in their interest and put in studios and uh their own places to do holograms?
Well that's what I was hoping for.
If this was successful, which it was, um brings the cost way down.
And you don't have to have a big table like mine either.
And you know how many people want to do holograms using a laser pointer.
Right.
You know?
I mean you see the emails, I see them all the time.
Imagine now that you can write back to those people and tell them, yes, you can do a hologram with a laser pointer.
Yes, that's a great feeling.
Yeah, it's incredible.
Well I want to congratulate you Steve.
Um it's not too often that we get somebody on the show that uh has done what you've done and I admire you because you didn't listen to what other people were telling you and you just went ahead and did it anyway, which I really liked.
Thanks.
I want to thank you for coming on and I want to uh uh tell the listeners that you can go to the 3d imagery dot com and I'll have a link for that uh is it W W first?
Yeah.
Okay.
So we've got W Ww dot three D imagery dot com.
You'll see a link for it right on the uh Holo Talk page.
You can click on that link and go over to the site.
And let me ask you this before we close it out, do you think you're going to put anything on your website about your experiment and results?
Most definitely.
Most definitely it will happen in the next couple of months.
And one other thing, um we had I talked to you about um finding a cheaper film too.
Oh okay.
And Yes, that's right.
Yes.
You were working with the tech path.
Um that didn't turn out and I did several exposures um using different um angles between the beams and that's pretty restrictive.
I mean if you try to get down to ten degree difference and keep your spatial frequency down then you you're not you're not very practical anymore.
But um I did call Kodak today and found out the Kodak still produces the SO two fifty three holographic film and that's in sheet, four by five sheets, comes twenty five in a box for sixty one fifty five.
So we're looking at uh less expense there too.
Yeah.
And in small quantities then you have to buy a lot of the other films as well.
Right.
And if you call Kodak at um eight hundred uh two four two two four two four they'll send out the specs of that film.
Well Steve, thank you very much.
Uh hang on the line for a minute after I close this out, I'm gonna pick up the phone.
Okay?
Thank you.
Okay.